hello my name is Edward Wilson Edward
ole Wilson and I'm professor emeritus at
Harvard University where I have been it
amazes me for 68 years coming there as a
graduate student long ago and spending
my career there i originate admire rigea
nated from the deep south and that's
where I developed an interest in Natural
History and then increasingly in insects
I'm an entomologist and then finally
turning to ants as the principal objects
of my professional research and other
scholarly activities
most people would say about ants next to
asking the question now what do I do
about the ones in my kitchen my issue
the question of how have they become so
successful what is their altruism and
colony organization
what is this unique or special about
that that makes them the equivalent of
humans among all other animals and the
answer to that is first of all they've
had a long time as a group of organisms
in which to by evolution perfecting
their way of life they're 150 million
years old whereas humans have been on
the earth in the form of Homo sapiens
our form for only about 200 to 300
thousand years and during that time the
ants have perfected colonial
organization based upon altruism and it
is in altruism and the peculiarities of
social organization in the ants that
scientists turned in order to learn more
about these traits in human beings
through comparison and answers gotten
that way in part because of group
selection recently I tracked through the
whole history of life and through fossil
evidence and other forms of evidence the
times that advanced social behavior has
come into existence throughout an entire
pageant of life evolving on earth the
number has come into being I found
there's at least 17 times and one of
those times humans
or another and ants have clearly
advanced to that level because they come
from groups with insects that tend to
form groups anyway there are and
societies and at first the stages were
very pretty but then as the groups
competed with other groups the form of
the cooperation became more intense and
and more varied and complicated and ants
developed true alkyl altruism in which
individual ant workers sacrificed
themselves as needed just to protect the
colony and that is the form of their out
rhythm it's absolute and has a minimum
of character in it that adds benefit to
the individual ant that's not the kind
of society we want to become I think
we'd like to move in the opposite
direction but at least answer there for
us to study to learn about how they are
dominant why they are dominant the
effect they have on the environment and
then their advanced social behavior
including algorithm how that is
contributed to their success as the
major insect group in the environment